yo what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd here with another
unboxing and first impressions video for
you guys this one as you can see is from
the folks the kind folks at thinkgeek
and their website is thinkgeek.com you
can obviously check that out in the
description of this video
and they were kind enough to send me a
few samples actually for a review video
but this is just going to be the
unboxing and first impressions video of
the products in this package so uh let's
just get into the first impression so
here we go
uh as you can see it's they they
packaged it quite
quite uh nicely it says uh fragile and
handle with care
so
it did ship relatively quickly actually
um but we're just gonna get right into
this and see
um
see what our first impressions are so
here we go
uh looks like it'll open this way this
box so let's look
there's more than one opening to this
box okay
well actually it doesn't look like this
box is going to be the easiest in the
world to open so
i'm probably just going to accept the
box and cut the actual box
but this shouldn't harm the things
inside the box because actually you know
you shake the box around you feel that
it doesn't fill up the entire box so
anyway
this is just uh the first impressions
video so the first thing that we see
here if i can move this off to the side
uh does this come out the back okay so
there's two bags this one right here is
the actual uh what looks like the
speaker uh what does it say here this oh
you can see this is the mirror all right
uh so this is actually kind of special
i'll show you guys uh in a second after
i get everything out the box
so let's see if we can get this
and the second thing is a uh thermometer
so i'm going to show you guys a review
of both these things and the packaging
shipments no big deal
again you can see that's thinkgeek.com
so i can i can pretty much move the box
off here
um
but this is probably going to be the
quickest review video i've ever ever
done but this is just the first
impressions it's actually a mirror um
kind of like security mirror you can
actually see me there in kind of a
little bit
but i'll get you guys a review video on
that just to show you guys exactly what
it entails how you can use it and the
second thing which will probably be a
much more detailed review video is the
outdoor window thermometer which is uh
something as you can see here that goes
inside uh it's a large lcd that mounts
to the outside of a glass window but i
projects the actual information inside
so it's going to be pretty cool to
actually check this this kind of stuff
out and show you guys how it works how
accurate it is maybe you want to check
one of these out it looks like it's
pretty cool and i'm probably just going
to put one right outside the window
outside my desk
uh so yeah this has been the unboxing
and first impressions video of uh the
the kind folks that think geek they were
able to send me a few of their own
products um and i'll definitely show you
guys as much as i can about these
products and hopefully you'll be able to
uh enjoy them if you do decide to pick
them up so again the link is in the
description and thank you for checking
out the unboxing and first impressions
video it was a pleasure and uh make sure
you stay tuned for the full review guys
peace